well to have for the first time somebody
who's I've been a big fan of for quite
some time and he star in with lil rel on
rel on Fox Sundays every single Sunday
at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time good to have
you Sinbad here on the rich eyes and
she'll tell you I love your show dude
this is unique I just I just you said is
unique thank you why do you love sports
so much I've always wanted one guys who
do good shows like this be I love sports
so much because the competition level
and I couldn't play it so I talk about
it for a living
because our two people ex players and
they're guys who love the game I just
lonely study it I'll do I do love you
know I love the intellectual aspect of
football I love baseball's intensity
just the the baseball playoffs this
month I can't get enough of it are you
serious
I can't get it now because I really look
baseball was never baseball I don't know
why I was never my thing maybe because I
sucked at it you did I did that's why I
was terrible out of town my dad told me
get off the team please because baseball
games take so long he said please I'm
tired of sitting in his son this in the
state of Michigan yes stated Mishka I
had ADHD so they will put me out in left
field and I'll be running around throw
my mitt up in the air and stuff yeah and
they said what's your son doing there
was no name for the disease yet so I
look like I was special
no kid somebody I said please just get a
uniform back okay and so then what you
play as a kid then um basketball I
sucked until 10th grade and then and
then it got real what was your game like
man inside outside take I love blockage
I thought could be sent feet tall in my
mind I was 7 feet tall
I wanted to block air by shots yeah I
want to stop with him going to hole I
want to dunk on people and growing up in
the state of Michigan who was your guy
that you wanted to be like oh man you
know what a guy in my home named Alani
multum or okay honey
Aulani montemor went on and you try to
further make lani malta more was like
dr. J giant hands
incredible ballplayer race and Ben
hunter Michigan has so many athletes
Ellis ho went to Western Miss University
6-4-3 some hit 40 points in the game
reason College they won two state champs
of two years in rows Michigan 65 66
undefeated Ben Harbor Tigers incredible
man so would you root for the Pistons
growing up did you know it's funny I
like to piss this by little close to
cago right so was norm van Laer
walkers from Benton Harbor so I watched
Chet Walker with Bob love so I was
closer I could see more games in Chicago
right so I was a trader know right did
you ever planning these NBA celebrity
games Sinbad I did I played Matt and st.
John's at just school I played st.
John's against with Houdini a new
addition that was the last Monday's were
beat up but that's the last time I
played cuz you see Kevin Hart thinks
that he I hate fake it celebrity can't
play ball players well he thinks Justin
Bieber with a basketball stop it
I just want to sit with a paintball gun
in the rafters and get off the team get
off this thing to me no Brandon I can
play okay he can shoot he's about to say
who who Brian Brian begging I can go Oh
God
from from new addition dancing ballers
house it didn't Kevin Hart gave it to
him because they like this you know that
guy on the team hey man he tries hard
anybody else
I wish we had fire for him if he could
jump if he could shoot if he could play
yeah but it's hard so he wins because
he's that guy that coaches lie about
because I tried to the guy who's six
nine you wish me to work harder but you
really want 569 dudes but you tell the
six I do look man I would take 12 of him
for his heart no you wouldn't they
wouldn't so are you saying that if his
name was Smith he wouldn't have won
these trophies or he really does have
heart no if he wasn't Kevin Hart okay I
said he wasn't Kevin Hart
he got crossed over by the girls from
Little League baseball remember the
little basketball players that played
Little League there was a picture she
crossed him over crossed him he fell
back as a Monet Davis cross the ball she
crossed him over cuz she's about she's a
baller she crossed him up man you run
out to Jim you just you run out yeah a
shame you run out and you never come
back
quit in Hollywood you never come back
never come back you got any good
Michaels stories from back in the day
Michael man you know Michael I would
take my kids out of school because I was
divorced at the time my wife would drop
kids off school yeah I snatched him we
would fly Chicago for the games cuz the
opening of Chicago ball is that Chicago
Bulls I had a phone I gave my son there
was a bachelor opened up mm-hmm
on the ring but
Chicago Bulls theme song man I remember
that I love going to the Bulls games but
I remember when I was at the game when
Allen Iverson crossed him mm-hmm
and my son looked at me I said shh don't
say none
just don't say just act like it didn't
happen this did not happen I just I do
remember the old Chicago Stadium moments
prior the United State him I could hear
the song in my head right now do you
have that song yes Scotty you got it he
could pretty good bring it up oh you got
that's like was that not the best was
that not the best intro there it is
they sit in a basketballs opening the
phone is ringing and the top of the
stadium opening I'm a forgery and I let
a ring for a while so I get the whole
thing wrong he's like mr. phone call a
theme song go I said I bought my son but
I was still his phone and in his room
from no ringtone
there's a ball we'd be outside running
trying to get in the gym because my kids
were depressed if they missed his intro
and the lights would be going all over
the court I know oh now you see it now
LeBron's here in town or you know what
that's not me LeBron I took so many hits
LeBron I tell people it was Bill Russell
those Wilt Chamberlain then it was dr. J
there was a mic and I quit watching ball
for a while well Mike retired and then I
started watching LeBron and it was so
much pressure on this kid in high school
I said there's no way he can do this in
the pros there's no way and I said he's
18 destroying grown men I started
smiling said but he went to Cleveland I
cried that's it was in Cleveland but
he's never won a championship in
Cleveland and he showed me that give me
four kids give me a guy who drives the
ice cream truck
give me dude with four fingers and we
have a chance to go to the NBA Finals
that's who LeBron James is well he's got
more than that I think a Los Angeles
he's you know that just watching the
preseason I got so excited that's the
purple and gold stumble for the tight
pants you know I like a mr. Cleveland
the shorts yeah
around pants we got to do some about
that but other than that I'm good
you restored Sinbad you missed the whole
kobir if you were not it miss nothing
really okay okay okay I was about to say
nothing okay I'm good call me I'd miss
cuz I do remember I used to I used to do
I know you look man I'm a shake Shack's
my boy from Orlando from the time I saw
man Orlando Jack was my dude man know
what Kobe's a great play opens will put
out Kobe's great player was selfish mmm
when I say selfish he didn't toward the
end he could have been difference to
those young guys he could say hey man
short time let me show you some things
it's the end it was still hell it was
still young it's still just Elm now it's
it's interesting again that LeBron comes
here right now and it's exciting time
and all that sort of stuff and you
mentioned about how long he's been at it
I remember doing his high school
SportsCenter highlights with Stu Scott
Miller Scott would be sitting there and
we be what doing his highlights as a
high school player like I can't imagine
that happening now
I guess what Zion Zion Zion Zion is that
close right but it's still not it's
still not the Brahma Zion oh my god that
Duke team if they lose more than two
games they lose more than two games
that's like a that's a stupid team
that's a stupid college team Zion and
there's four guys on that team that are
beastly right I know we we saw the video
of him schooling these poor Canadian
kids ya know go to fighting ki saw video
of Williamson and I said if I'm an NBA
team that has no shot I'm tanking right
now
you know what and I'm in their best
probably that's what I'm saying they
keep saying there's two better than the
team but I'm like I look at Zion man I
watched I said I saw one of the
preseason games college people already
do what they do to the bran he was going
to the hole and they were doing this
like please don't dunk on me mm-hmm it's
gonna be fun I know it will be and I
hate Duke and I got a watch
I hate Duke but I like him so much I'll
watch Duke why do you like why do you
hate times and never lounder why they
bother me okay I'm at Michigan for I was
at the game I was at the game which one
when he called timeout
that's Michigan North Carolina I was
second you were at the Chris Webber a
game with my brother and recall timeout
I looked and I said everybody in the
stands did this hmm and I love Chris I
said I took my brother Chris was gonna
be a great Pro I said this day will
always mess with him this day will
always that's something no matter what
happens as great as he as great athlete
this day will always haunt you
he's handled it so well you back your
mind you back your mind it's like you
like we're dating Halle Berry or
something and you broke up we're in high
school
you'll never be anybody Halle and you're
like I take Ali to the problem I let it
go in the n-c-double-a championship camp
yeah I hear so you're a Michigan State
guy not a Michigan guy huh yeah now why
would you be Michigan State at the
southwest corner of the state because it
was more the more public school kids it
was a real kids it's like I went to a
basketball camp when Mike Robinson was
playing and Gus kanakas was coaching
okay and I always like to UM was always
the rich kids and five black basketball
player is not the same man you know that
was the money school U of M was the
money school Michigan State with the
farmers and the urban kids they were
trying to get in
yeah U of M was like this no man when I
went to Michigan the basketball team
Antoine Jubair Georgia bear that he
tried the judge but Jim come on man yeah
he played against Benton Harbor gets a
high school team is Christmas term and I
said oh Jesus boys bad he was head judge
was bad he was great he bring the
Simpsons him and Gary grant Gary grant
with a back Larry Grant I keep trying to
tell people that cooking with Gary grant
uh-uh come on man come on come on man
the guards ahead when they would do when
they were nasty
they called him baby Mike man come on oh
the baby Mike and for the Clippers yes
in the eighties yes yes look it's Harold
miner was the old man it was crazy but
that's not come on man play with Chicago
Bulls play with the Lakers why am i
trippin I just saw another day you got
that over there
you are you don't be allergic to Google
here he's trying to look up jump out the
gym didn't had knee surgery my mind I'm
losing my mind it's okay don't worry
we've got the internet to back you up
Sinbad don't worry about it come on in
the meantime close Jackson would keep
him around kill Jackson loved him is
this is not a zit Ron Harper you rot huh
okay
his two sons have you seen sue sons mmm
Oh God
insane your son is rel on yes on rel yes
you haven't blast doing this or what you
know I'm having fun me at first I was I
was avoiding trying to come back into a
sitcom right because I know if it's not
done right it's just bad jokes I want to
do like this is us or vampire I like
those two kind of things
okay I'm killing people I'm helping
people okay cuz that we get the full
spectrum of life but maybe yeah maybe
you're helping people by making them
laugh by killing it you know you don't
think about that I know what happens
yeah I think every comic desires to be
like I want to be drama I don't just
want people to see me it's fine I don't
know what happens we get the disease
yeah yeah I want to do drama but we are
drama most comics and as Haley most
comics are drama we are a lot to deal
with I did stand-up comedy in comm what
I did what I did at the University of
Michigan and I loved it and it's made
everything that I've ever done that much
easier it's the craziest job was the
best job because there's nothing there
is nothing like the immediacy of
laughter and it's just a holiday no left
that is the worst part of death of no
life also my I realized I might not be
cut out for it
when I met other comedians who are just
on average miserable people you know
comics 12 comments in the tortured you
know of comics in room nine will be
depressed I could never understand nine
why think he became comics think about
why does a person become a comic man
bully got jacked up didn't fit most
comets become comics it's very rare you
mean econo like me he just he's funny
he's happening it's rare you know or or
if your comic and you get mad one time
Wow mmm oh that's why I didn't know you
were like that you didn't know I get man
I can hit my car you didn't think I
would get my car go ladies man you
really smashed my car right so check out
again rel on Fox
Sundays at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time we do
a segment called celebrity true or false
where we ask you questions on your IMDB
or other articles that have been written
about whether they are I've read mostly
stuff so I said no okay let's say that
Mike Delta for celebrity true or false
with Sinbad here on the Rich Eisen
lettered in basketball twice for the
University of Denver true or false true
okay so you played college basketball
who was the best player you played
against at the University of Denver bird
as in Larry Larry Bird at the Terre
Haute Indiana at the upstate Christmas
tournament mm-hmm but is it interesting
behind it okay and if I can really tell
there right now okay Larry Berg Larry
Bird I've told the story before and I
should really tell it cuz he's a
different person now mhm
but he used a racial slur I won the guys
on my team no Kimmy punch Larry in the
face that happened they had at the
University of Denver yes I did not know
what he's not that guy now it's a
totally different thing but it was it
was and we said yeah that's a bad white
boy it was to birdsburg de cárcel
Webster and Larry Bird was on that team
and we said he's truth that cat is truth
now another another fact here true or
false
Sinbad you were on the 1983 season of
Star Search and was a finalist for
stand-up comedy you beat Dennis Miller
before losing to the gentlemen
eventually became the voice that
Cryptkeeper is that a true story that's
true what in the world was it like to be
on Star Search in 1903
I just thought sirs because I just
wanted to take a trip to LA went and
when I audition for Star Search they
turned the cameras off on me before we
got started they had a big audition and
I had feathered earrings and a blonde
hair and a jheri curl
I go bye-bye they tricked the cameras
off goodbye goodbye and then the guy
this rock'n'roll drew would Star Search
stayed behind
and said y'all need to see this other
guy and they looked for me and the
pencil broke when I try to sign my name
to sign up yeah so if
something's for he's gonna happen and
other comments call me man star sir is
looking for you but that's the joke we
should tell he starts looking for you
think I know really they're looking for
you they called me and that's how I got
started how many stars did you get at
the engine ah I know I went to that I
won like eight nine times in a row okay
and then I thought I won I thought I won
the finals I really thought it's hard to
be a sock puppet but I thought I lost a
damn sock what happened this I went to
reach for the check because the winner
is I went to be sure to check I said
John can see I said oh man
congratulations
nice man I turn into a fist man kiss of
death is to win it
mm-hmm because that never could you
think it means something you get a
hundred thousand dollars yeah but really
it means nothing so you just go back on
the road I went back to my real world I
got jobs from it and I was able to come
to Hollywood was Ed McMahon the host of
yes he was was he good - there's a good
dude good do man it was a few pops in
well you don't want you know if you
never saw that okay you know but you
never saw that mean we hear about it you
know we hear about you know he liked
beer do you sleep last one sweet it's in
fact true or false you were in the Air
Force and discharged for parking your
car in the wrong position no that was
the last reason that was that wasn't a
reason good I got discharged for
impersonating officers going AWOL and
that's one I did by accident wasn't even
on purpose it was it was foggy that
night the day I left on unli and I
parked in backwards think I did
everything right but I want to cross the
lines I didn't know some commander said
that's it I said no that's the one I
didn't do a purpose I did the other
several purpose but yeah what I didn't
do it that was the last straw because
that but it was the Air Force talent
show they got me be a comic comic so I
thank you military for that that was out
my mind
I shouldn't Air Force I was up my mind
mm-hmm and I joined my dad said you're
joining a place where they gonna tell
you what to do and you're like anybody
tell you what to do but you got
recruited to play basketball at the Air
Force can't probably recruited me say
what him and Hank Eagan where the
coaches at the Air Force Academy
Greg Papa Papa mayor Bob was cool I
guess I can tell it
not can't he want me sell it pop was
cool he later went oh he's cool pop was
cool
well I think he is no but cool not like
this pop is cool okay cool
can we read in between the lines oh I
mean he's cool like that cuz I was
remember telling some of the guys on the
team who's coaching goes I can't talk to
you can talk to you they don't know that
they don't need to know that oh is that
right yeah I like pop man so Gregg
Popovich recruited Sinbad yes to the Air
Force yes from which you were discharged
eventually yeah discharged for parking
in the among other things the things a
lot of things going on Sinbad you are
the man thank you for coming on here no
man thank you for having to have you
back anytime I love I love this place
I'm gonna take this place with me I
think please do it yeah I would love to
there be a home version of the Richards
each other that's fantastic and then I I
mean you love talking ball the franchise
this okay and I can do it at my house
let's do it anytime at sym bad bad on
tour dark white I could be you Sunday's
at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time
good to see you sir man you got a Sinbad
here in the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience